als erstes möchte ich ihn hier
vorschlagen eine Frau die etwas ganz
Besonderes werden soll nämlich die erste
in Ministerin der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland aus meiner Sicht ist das
auch Zeit dass wir eine so schwierige
Aufgabe dient der Sicherheit unseres
Landes verbunden ist in die Hände an der
erfahren und mit dem Thema bestens
bekannten Frau aus Deutschland legten
ich werde dazu vorschlagen dass Nancy
Faeser das machen soll sie kennen sie
als Fakten zum Landesvorsitzende der
hessischen SPD aber Sie sollten wissen
dass sie eine langjährige politische
Laufbahn hinter sich hat und ein ganz
ganz wichtiger Teil davon immerhin 12
Jahre war sie die innenpolitische
Sprecherin der hessischen
Landtagsfraktion das heißt das ist genau
ihr Thema dass sie niemals verlassen hat
vom Herzen sowieso nicht auch als sie
Vorsitzende der Fraktion im hessischen
Landtag wurde und auch natürlich in
nicht in all den schwierigen Jahren muss
darum den hessischen
nsu-untersuchungsausschuss zu begleiten
Nancy Faeser wird eine sehr sehr gute in
Ministerin Deutschland und ich freue
mich dass Sie mir zugesagt hat
[Applaus]
als zweites möchte ich ihn fast schon
einen Schlachtross 1 Niedersachsen Roste
vorstellen dass wir wieder in das
Kabinett
berufen wollen Hubertus Heil als
Bundesminister für Arbeit und Soziales
er hat wirklich eine ganz ganz
erfolgreiche Bilanz in den letzten vier
Jahren
vorzulegen hat dafür gesorgt dass in
Deutschland die Grundrente möglich wurde
er hat dafür gesorgt dass wir in
bestimmten Bereichen unseres
Arbeitsleben Bus schlimme
Ausbildungsverhältnisse geherrscht haben
neue Verhältnisse etablieren können die
besser die Recht und Ordnung auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt entsprechende an die
schlimmen Verhältnisse in der
Fleischbranche und der Fleischindustrie
oder an die wirklich schwierigen
Schicksals Situation der Paketboten in
Deutschland wir kennen ihn als
hartnäckig und klug als jemand der sein
Wort Machthaber der sich genau für die
Menschen und die Bürgern und Bürger
unseres Landes einsetzt um die es geht
wenn man Bundesminister für Arbeit und
Soziales ist und auf ihn warten große
neue Aufgaben die sich auch aus dem
verständigen der Künste ständigen der
künftigen Regierungsparteien ergeben ich
will nur erinnern an die Durchsetzung
eines erhöhten Mindestlohns von 12 € und
ich will nur erinnern an die wichtige
Aufgabe jetzt stabile rennen für die
Zukunft zu sichern zwei ganz große
herzensprojekte von mir aber ich bin
sicher auch von den meisten Bürgern und
Bürgern Hubertus Heil wird weiter ein
sehr guter Arbeits und Sozialminister
sein
[Applaus]
ja meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
ich bin Olaf Scholz meine
Sozialdemokratischen Partei sehr dankbar
dass ich diese wichtige Aufgabe für
unser Land fortführen kann als Arbeits
und Sozialminister steht man in diesen
Zeiten für großen Herausforderungen ich
bin mir dessen sehr sehr bewusst hier
geht es um mehr Respekt und mir
Leistungsgerechtigkeit Stichwort
Mindestlohn Tariflohn anständige
Arbeitsbedingungen es geht uns als SPD
aber auch um einen starken und
verlässlichen Sozialstaat der als
Partner für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
da ist der nicht vor der Nase sondern
zur Seite steht deshalb werden wir das
Bürgergeld einführen und wir werden für
soziale Sicherheit und
Leistungsgerechtigkeit auf durch stabile
Renten Sorgen mir zu Dieblich nicht dass
wir in diesem Wandel von Wirtschaft und
Arbeitswelt dafür sorgen dass die
Beschäftigten von heute auch die Chance
haben die Arbeit von morgen zu machen
Deutschland muss eine weiterbildungs
Republik werden und wir wollen dass alle
Menschen diesem Land teilhaben können
unabhängig von Geschlecht Herkunft oder
eben auch der Frage ob man eine
Beeinträchtigung hat oder nicht wir
wollen einer Gesellschaft die
zusammenhält ich freue mich auf die
Arbeit in dieser Fortschritt Koalition
und ich werde mit all dem was ich kann
und vermag für sozialen Fortschritt in
Deutschland arbeiten in dieser Regierung
herzlichen Dank
Sicherheit wird in dieser Regierung in
den Händen starker Frauen liegen deshalb
will ich als
Bundesminister der Verteidigung
Christine lambrecht vorschlagen
Christine lambrecht
ist eine erfahrene Politikerin eine
erfahrene Ministerin die gegenwärtig
sogar zwei Ressorts leitet und das ist
schon mal eine der ganz ganz großen
Kompetenzen und Fähigkeiten die man
verfügen über die man verfügen muss wenn
man das Verteidigungs fürs Ohr leiten
will das ist ein großes Ressort das eine
wichtige Verantwortung für unser Land
und für unsere Sicherheit hat die Frauen
und Männer in der Bundeswehr haben auch
verdient dass jemand vorne an steht im
Ministerium der sich für sie einsetzt
ein Herz für sie hat und dafür sorgt
dass sie gut ausgestattet werden aber
dies auch kann und das ist bei Christine
lambrecht exakt der Fall sie hat in all
den Aufgaben die sie zuletzt
wahrgenommen hat gezeigt welche großen
Fähigkeiten in ihr stecken und sie wird
eine ganz ganz bedeutende
Verteidigungsministerin der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland sein
vielen Dank für viele wird die
Nominierung als Verteidigungsministerin
eine Überraschung sein für mich ist das
erstens ein großer Vertrauensbeweis
lieber Olaf Scholz wofür ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken möchte und es ist
eine Herausforderung und wer mich kennt
und bei Olaf Scholz ist das der Fall der
weiß dass ich gerne große
Herausforderungen auch annehmen und
genauso werde ich das auch in diesem Amt
tun die Soldatinnen und Soldaten der
Bundeswehr haben es verdient dass wir
sie mit Anerkennung und mit Respekt dass
er mit Anerkennung und Respekt begegnen
und möchte da ausdrücklich auch die
Reservisten miteinbeziehen denn die
erleben ja was sie Großartiges
beeindruckendes leisten hier lebend
jetzt in der Korona Pandemie die haben's
aber auch im Sommer beim Hochwasser im
Aartal erlebt und deswegen müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass nicht nur das ganze
ausgedrückt wird in Ordnung sondern auch
in Tat und dazu gehört Beschaffung wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sie
entsprechend aus
wir müssen diesen Beruf attraktiv machen
damit der Demokratie Fest der
Mammographie fest ist und eine
Herausforderung wird sein aber die ist
ganz wichtig dass wir dafür sorgen dass
Auslandseinsätze in Zukunft ständig
evaluiert werden immer wieder überprüft
werden und auch eine Exit-Strategie
vorhanden ist wir haben gesehen beim
Afghanistan-Einsatz wie wichtig das ist
und dafür will ich mich einsatzfähigen
freue ich mich auf diese große
Herausforderung
ein Thema ist in diesen Tagen und seit
zwei Jahren in aller Munde und
ein Thema macht viele besorgt seitdem
die Pandemie in der Welt ausgebrochen
ist doch unser Land erreicht hat wir
sind jetzt so lange schon dabei zu
versuchen die Virusinfektion im Griff zu
bekommen immer wieder mit Erfolgen
wieder mit Rückschlägen und natürlich
haben wir bei dieser Gelegenheit
festgestellt wie gut es ist dass wir ein
ordentliches Gesundheitssystem haben
aber wie viel besser es wäre wenn wir
ein noch viel besseres Gesundheitssystem
hätten bei dem Aldi Schwächen und
Schwierigkeiten die wir nun noch mal neu
kennengelernt haben nicht mehr da wären
und wir uns auf dieses Gesundheitssystem
mit aller Kraft verlassen können als
Bürgen und Burger das ist glaube ich
auch ganz wichtig wenn wir daran denken
dass so viele dort arbeiten die
Pflegekräfte die Pflegerin und Pfleger
die Ärztin Ärzte die mit ganzem Herzen
dabei sind und ist auch verdient haben
dass das eine erste Parität in der
Politik der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
wird ein gutes Gesundheitssystem mit
guten Arbeitsbedingungen und guten
Angeboten für die Bürger und Bürger zu
etablieren und für mich ist ganz wichtig
dass wir dann natürlich auch im Blick
haben dass die Pandemie noch lange nicht
vorbei ist und deshalb haben sich anders
kann man das gar nicht sagen bestimmt
die meisten Bürgern und Bürger dieses
Landes gewünscht dass der nächste
Gesundheitsminister vom Fach ist das
wirklich gut kann und dass er Karl
Lauterbach heißt er wird
ja vielen Dank Olaf ich darf es
vielleicht Sommer für das Vertrauen der
Partei ganz herzlich bedanken für diese
wichtige Aufgabe aber ich möchte mich
auch bedanken für die vielen zustimmen
antworte dir dass der Bevölkerung
bekommen habe es würde ein wichtiges
Abend werden wir müssen diese Pandemie
bekämpfen die Panne wie wird länger
dauern als viele denken wir werden das
aber schaffen impfen wird die zentrale
Rolle spielen aber nicht nur und wir
werden darüber hinaus das
Gesundheitssystem Stärken Olaf Scholz
hat eben schon darauf hingewiesen mit
uns wird es keine
Leistungskürzungen im Gesundheitswesen
geben ganz im geben Tage werden das
System wieder robuster machen wir sind
stolz auf ein gutes Gesundheitssystem
wir werden es benötigen wir werden den
Kampf mit der Pandemie gewinnen und für
weitere Pandemien werden wir besser
gerüstet sein als wir für diese gewesen
sind vielen Dank für diese Zustimmung
vielen Dank für das Vertrauen
[Applaus]
eine der ganz ganz großen
Herausforderungen dieses Landes ist
dafür zu sorgen dass wir genügend und
bezahlbaren Wohnraum haben das ist ein
Thema dass die Bürgern und Bürger jeden
Tag umtreibt viele machen sich Sorgen ob
sie die Wohnung in der sie jetzt wohnen
noch leisten können ob Sie wenn Sie
umziehen müssen eine neue Betrachtung
Wohnung finden ob es überhaupt genügend
gibt und ob das mit den Bedürfnissen
übereinstimmend die man hat an den Orten
wo man lebt und arbeitet das ist nicht
so einfach und deshalb haben wir uns
sehr dafür eingesetzt dass diese
wichtige Aufgabe wieder die Bedeutung
bekommt die Sie schon einmal
insbesondere
sonst hatte und haben dafür gerungen
dass die künftige Bundesregierung wieder
ein eigenes Bauministerium bekommt es
geht um viele viele Wohnung es geht um
viele geförderte Wohnung und ich möchte
vorschlagen dass Klara geywitz die
nächste Bundesministerin wird die das
Thema Bauen für sich zur Aufgabe macht
sie hat die Erfahrung dazu sie hat in
der Kommunalpolitik in der
Stadtverordnetenversammlung gelebt
Themen verarbeitet sie hat als Landes
Landtagsabgeordnete sich mit den Fragen
aus der Perspektive der Länder
auseinandergesetzt und sie hat auch
viele Erfahrung in der Führung der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei in
Brandenburg gewonnen und ist jetzt
stellvertretende Parteivorsitzende
der SPD Klara geywitz ist für mich eine
der ganz talentierten Politikerin dieses
Landes und deshalb bin ich froh dass sie
diese schwere Aufgabe muss um richtig
was konkretes geht anpacken will packen
mit vielen Männern und Frauen auf dem
Bau die dafür morgen dass es wieder
genug Wohnung gibt
ich bedanke mich bei sozialen
persönlich bei Olaf
sein darf
das ist das Thema Sicherheit die
Mieterinnen und Mieter im Land brauchen
Sicherheit dass sie nicht aus ihrer
Wohnung vertrieben werden weil die
Mieten übermäßig steigen sie brauchen
Sicherheit dass sie auch im Alter noch
in ihrer Wohnung leben können und nicht
ausziehen müssen weil sie nicht mehr in
den vierten Stock kommen und sie
brauchen auch Sicherheit dass sie in
einem Stadtteilleben der sich so
gestaltet dass sie gerne weiter da
wohnen wo sie seit Jahrzehnten wohnen
das ist eine große Herausforderung auf
die ich mich sehr freue herzlichen Dank
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Wicklung ein ganz wichtiges Thema für
Deutschlands Verortung in der Welt wir
haben eine Aufgabe nicht nur für uns
sondern auch für die übrige Welt und das
wird genau in diesem Ministerium
wahrgenommen wir müssen sicherstellen
dass es überall gute
Entwicklungsperspektiven gibt wir müssen
Hunger und Armut bekämpfen aber wir
müssen auch dafür Sorge tragen dass z.b.
nicht unsere Welt bedroht wird durch den
Klimawandel und die Klimaflüchtlinge die
daraus erwachsen mögen deshalb ist das
eine sehr sehr zentrale Herausforderung
und ich bin sehr froh dass die
Sozialdemokratische Partei die Ehre hat
dieses Ministerium zu besetzen ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass die
Svenja Schulze genau die richtige
Ministerin für diese Aufgabe ist sie hat
gerade zuletzt bei der Klimakonferenz in
Glasgow noch mal gezeigt wie sehr sie
international vernetzt ist wie sehr sie
internationales Parkett beherrscht was
ihr eben auch zu dieser Aufgabe dazu
gehört aber wie sehr sie auch globale
Themen die uns dann auch hierzulande
berühren immer schon umgetrieben haben
und mit der Erfahrung im Rücken Sie sie
in ihrer bisherigen Aufgabe als
Umweltminister in gewonnen hat ist sie
genau die Richtige für dieses Ressort
ich bin sehr dankbar dass Svenja Schulze
nun die dritte Sozialdemokraten im Amt
der Entwicklungshilfe Ministerin sein
wird und ich bin sehr stolz dass es
Svenja Schulze ist
es ist mir eine große Ehre im ersten
Kabinett Scholz den Bereich der
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit und der
Entwicklungspolitik zu verantworten
Entwicklungspolitik hat eine lange
Tradition in der SPD mit ihr sind solche
Namen wie er hat Eppler Egon Bahr Marie
Schlei und Heidemarie Wieczorek-Zeul
verbunden und ich freue mich jetzt als
Sozialdemokrat in diesem Bereich weiter
verantworten zu können ich habe den
Deutschland mich für die Transformation
für die Klimaveränderung für die ganzen
Veränderungen die wir vor uns haben in
den letzten Jahren engagiert und jetzt
geht es um die internationale
Solidarität und die globale Ebene die
ich in Zukunft verantworten weil das ist
eine große Ehre und ich bin sehr froh
dabei sein zu können
[Applaus]
ja dann gehört zu einer richtigen
Regierung auch ein Chef des
Bundeskanzleramts das wird niemanden
überraschen wird Wolfgang Schmidt sein
und ich muss und will an dieser Stelle
gerne sagen dass ich mich bedanke für
die langjährige Zusammenarbeit die wir
bisher hatten und dass ich deshalb auch
weiß dass das leise Geschäft dass dort
betrieben wird auch von Wolfgang Schmidt
gut vorangetrieben wird denn es muss ja
alles miteinander funktionieren was die
Regierung weil die unterschiedlichen
Parteien die unterschiedlichen
Ministerien voranbringen wollen und das
ist eine gute gute Unterstützung wenn
das mit all der Kompetenz und Erfahrung
der letzten Jahre dann an dieser Stelle
fortgesetzt werden kann ich bin dankbar
dass er diese Aufgabe wahrnimmt
auch ich bin natürlich dankbar und ich
freue mich darauf die Aufgabe des Chefs
Bundeskanzleramt es ist mitzuhelfen dass
die Regierung gut arbeiten kann das will
ich machen mit den hier Anwesenden
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber natürlich
auch mit den Minister und Ministerinnen
der Grünen und der FDP das gilt aber
auch für die Zusammenarbeit mit dem
Deutschen Bundestag den Bundesrat und in
16 Ländern wir leben das jetzt in der
Korona Pandemie wie wichtig das ist und
auch darüber hinaus bei der großen
transformationsaufgaben beim Ausbau von
Windenergie und Solarenergie kommt es
darauf an dass die Zusammenarbeit mit
den Ländern gut klappt und ich will
dafür sorgen dass Olaf Scholz den Rücken
frei hat damit der das machen kann was
er versprochen hat ordentlich zu
regieren
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren es
ist mir eine besondere Wesen am Samstag
dass die Sozialdemokratische Partei den
Koalitionsvertrag dieser kommenden Ampel
zu fast 99% zugestimmt hat und heute
morgen macht es mich sehr froh in einer
Reihe mit
herausragenden fähigen
Sozialdemokratinnen und Sozialdemokraten
zu stehen die gerade eben vom Präsidium
auch einstimmig bestätigt worden sind
wir sind also stehen als SPD mit großer
Freude an der Seite und hinter diesen
Ministerinnen und Minister und natürlich
unserem
demnächst bald Kanzler Olaf Scholz diese
Sozialdemokratinnen und Sozialdemokraten
werden gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass wir
endlich wissensbasierte
Krisenbewältigung haben dass wir in der
Gesundheitsversorgung bekommen dass wir
in Arbeitsmarkt und ist ein Sozialstaat
bekommen der die ins 21 Jahrhundert
passen wir werden für bezahlbares und
klimagerechtes wohnen Sorgen wir sorgen
für Innere und äußere Sicherheit für
einen modernen Staat und wir sorgen auch
für gerechte Teilhabe nachhaltige
Teilhabe in aller Welt und natürlich
auch in Deutschland das freut mich ganz
besonders heute diese Minister und
Ministerinnen rege auch mit präsentieren
zu dürfen als Parteivorsitzende
ja wir sind angetreten für Kontinuität
und Wandel wir haben große Aufgaben vor
uns und Kontinuität und Wandel haben wir
nicht nur mit diesem Koalitionsvertrag
beschrieben und mit dem was wir uns
jetzt vorgenommen haben sondern für
Kontinuität und Wandel steht auch dieses
künftige Kabinett bzw in diesem Fall der
sozialdemokratische Teil dieses Kabinett
und ich bin sehr froh über dieses Team
das jetzt hier auf der Bühne steht als
er schon mal gesagt für mich ist das ein
Schluss. Aber was für einen schönen
Schlusspunkt kann es geben wenn man
gleichzeitig sehen kann welchen Anfang
ist jetzt gibt und dass heute ist der
Tag an dem Nikolaus groko aus ist und
habe jetzt Glück gehabt dass der
Nikolaus nicht ganz schlüssig geworden
ist ich wünsche euch allen viel Glück
danke schön die Bühne ist voll und wir
fangen an mit einigen wenigen Fragen
Martin greife vom Handelsblatt die erste
das Mikrofon müsste da hinkommen können
[Applaus]
zu äußern
die nächste Frage Cerstin gammelin
Süddeutsche Zeitung
ja schaue ich hätte zwei Fragen wenn ich
darf R2 die erste sie haben ja gesagt
das soll Parität geben aber wenn von 17
posten 8 mit Frauen besetzt sind ist das
meine Meinung nach nicht die Hälfte und
die zweite Teil Frage ist die SPD hat
ihren Wahlsieg ja auch sehr fehlen
Direktmandaten im Osten in den fünf und
neun Bundesländern zu verdanken wenn ich
ihr Kabinett anschaue da ist dann eine
Frau aus dem Osten dabei ist das nicht
ange ist das angemessen aus ihrer Sicht
der schönen Dank für die Frage in der
Tat die Parität ist mir wichtig dass wir
werden vom 16 Mindestlohn im Minister
Nacht Männer und acht Frauen sein und
selbstverständlich wird es dann noch ein
Bundeskanzler geben der für alle
gemeinsam zuständig ist und sich für
diese Fragen einsetzen ich glaube das
ist auch gut ist dass die
Sozialdemokratische Partei sich
entschlossen hat vier Ministerin und
drei Minister in das Kabinett zu
entsenden und das ist glaube ich auch
ein Zeichen dafür dass das tief
verankert ist und das nicht nur von mir
so gesehen wird sondern von allen und
besonders stolz bin ich darauf das
gerade so
resource bei dem das keineswegs in der
Tradition liegt jetzt von Frauen geführt
werden ich mache das noch mal hier klar
da stehen sie die künftige Innenminister
und die künftige Vertrag
wow Ministern aus meiner Sicht ein ganz
ganz bemerkenswerte Zeichen und
vielleicht auch das noch ist es gut dass
wir eine große
Vertretung all der unterschiedlichen
Bereiche unseres Landes in dem Kabinett
wiederfinden und das mit Klara geywitz
eine ostdeutsche Ministerin wird das ist
auch etwas ganz ganz bedeutendes
übrigens auch im Hinblick auf dieses
ganz konkrete bevor das will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen und wie schon
angekündigt werden wir ja dann die
weiteren Entscheidungen treffen in
Hinblick z.b. auf die parlamentarischen
Staatssekretär und Staatssekretär und
die Staatsministerin Staatsminister und
noch das wird noch mal eine weitere
Gelegenheit sein klar zu machen wie wir
genau zu den Dingen stehen die wir
vorher gesagt haben wir setzen sie
nämlich um
die nächste Frage Tim braune
Scholze am Donnerstag findet eine
erneute Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zur
Pandemie Stadt sehen sie noch Bedarf für
Nachbesserung für Feintuning gegenüber
dem vorangegangenen Beschluss und noch
eine Frage zur Lage in Ostdeutschland
dort haben viele Leute die Bilder
entsetzt als einen Fackel tragen damop
vor das Haus von Frau Köpping gezogen
ist besorgt sie diese Lage und finding
auch vor dem Hintergrund der Diskussion
um die Einführung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht
zunächst mal will ich auf die letzte
Frage eingehen die sie dort zugestellt
haben aus meiner Sicht ist das ganz
furchtbar was wir dafür Bilder gesehen
haben und noch viel furchtbarer ist da
was passiert ist und das dürfen wir uns
als Land nicht gefallen lassen ich finde
das ist die ganz klare Botschaft die von
uns allen ausgehen muss als Demokraten
und Demokraten und deshalb bin ich sehr
sehr sicher dass ich da nicht alleine
stehe und auch nicht die
Sozialdemokratische Partei sind viele
andere das entschieden zurückweisen
werden für mich ist es so dass wir auch
niemanden damit durchkommen lassen
dürfen dass er irgendwie
vergrätzt ist und deshalb solche Dinge
tun darf in der Welt in der wir leben
gibt es viele Sachen über die wir
unterschiedliche Meinung haben können
und die müssen und dürfen wir
diskutieren und natürlich ist es auch
erlebt erlaubt
engagiert zu diskutieren aber dass das
ist als Bedrohung gemeint und das
sollten wir sollten nicht so tun als ob
es nicht auch genau das gewesen ist eine
Bedrohung einer demokratischen fleißigen
und ganz tollen Politikerin in Sachsen
und das ist unser Geschäft als alle
Demokrat und Demokraten dass wir das
zurückweisen
ansonsten gilt für die Pandemie dass es
niemals den Punkt gibt wo man alles
getan hat und deshalb wären wir bei all
den Beratung die wir demnächst haben
immer diese Frage neu wegen muss noch
etwas gemacht werden bin froh über die
dramatischen Fortschritte die wir letzte
Woche erzählt haben die jetzt ja genau
in den Gesetzgebungsprozess einmünden
Rolf Mützenich steht da hinten der
Fraktionsvorsitzende
Sozialdemokratischen Partei und der
kämpft gerade sehr sehr engagiert dafür
dass das auch ein sehr schnelles
Gesetzgebungsverfahren wird damit die
Instrumente über die
ein rechtzeitig zur Verfügung stehen ich
würde ja gerne zu mehr Parität auch bei
den Fragen aufwerfen aufrufen jetzt aber
erstmal Gordon repinski mit der
vorletzten Frage ja Herr Scholz und Frau
Feser zwei kurze Fragen Vorfilter sie
sind für viele überraschende Personalie
weil man sie eigentlich auf dem Schirm
hatte als Spitzenkandidaten für die
hessische Landtagswahlen in zwei Jahren
über die Frage gelöst dann sich darüber
schon Gedanken gemacht und Herr Scholz
vielleicht noch eine Frage Carsten
Schneider hatte die Unterstützung der
ostdeutschen Landesverbänden viele haben
ihnen im Kabinett gesehen das ist ja
jetzt nicht
wo wo sehen Sie Carsten Schneider
schon Dank für Ihre Fragen vielleicht
darf ich dann kurz zu beiden auch was
sagen es ist klar hier wird einen
Kabinettsposten besetzt und den geht es
ja zum der wird wahrgenommen das ist
eine Sache die man mit langer
Perspektive vorantreiben muss und alle
anderen Fragen werden in Hessen
entschieden wenn sie soweit sind glaube
das ist das was ich berichten kann auch
aus unseren Gesprächen und ansonsten
habe ich ja schon gesagt dass wir alle
als sozialdemokratische Partei unsere
große Aufgabe sehen in der Regierung in
der Fraktion aber natürlich auch im
Hinblick auf all die weiteren Aufgaben
die noch konkret von uns wahrgenommen
werden müssen das ist ja jetzt ein ganz
ganz intensives Geschäft nicht so wie in
USA wo tausende Stellen irgendwie in
einem transition Prozesse neu besetzt
werden aber es sind schon eine ganze
Menge und mein persönliches Credo ist
das sehr sehr gut zu machen und da kann
ich Ihnen sagen dass ich das im tiefsten
Einvernehmen mache auch mit cas
Schneider und auch mit dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei weil die
sind ganz ganz wichtig dafür dass uns
diese Sache in den nächsten Jahren
gelingt und das werden sie auch merken
bei all dem was wir noch zu entscheiden
haben
bei lauterbach über eine Frage an Sie
ein ganz besonderes Augenmerk wird jetzt
darauf liegen welche Akzente sie als
Gesundheitsminister in der Pandemie
Bekämpfung setzen wollen können Sie uns
da schon mal ein bisschen ihre Gedanken
mitteilen und was glauben Sie welche
Rolle Corona für unser Weihnachtsfest
spielen wird
Frage die es zu direkt an Karl
Lauterbach gerichtet dass ich sie nicht
einfach beantworten will aber wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass wir ein bisschen
jetzt den Anstand wahren aus unserer
Sicht jedenfalls und am Mittwoch wird
eine Regierung gebildet und dann stehen
in diese Frauen und Männer als
Ministerin und Minister zur Verfügung
aber ich denke mal zwei Sätze zum ganz
ganz leicht was im Vordergrund jetzt
natürlich stehen muss dass wir in den
Wochen die wir noch haben die Fallzahlen
so stark absenken dass wir möglichst
gute Weihnachtsferien feiern können und
auch reisen können also ein richtiges
Ziel muss sein die Fallzahlen so starke
runterzubringen dass wir ohne die
Menschen zu gefährden Reisen empfehlen
können wenn der Wert legen großen Wert
legen
schönen Dank für Ihr Interesse und
sie werden diese Frauen und Männer noch
öfter sehen und in allen Details
kennenlernen sie werden finden es sind
sehr gute Frauen und Männer
[Applaus]
er hofft
bisschen Pierre auf seine Mühen zu
leiten mal sehen ob es aufgeht Karl
Lauterbach hat ja genervt in der Korona
Krise das muss man sagen wer hat in
jeder Talkshow gesessen zum Glück auch
bei uns ist total streitbar hat sich
offen mit uns auch gestritten hat sich
hierbei Bild live auch entschuldigt hat
aber eben auch ja wirklich penetrant
genervt auch den aktuellen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Jens Spahn
weißt du wie er darauf reagiert hat hat
er das für möglich gehalten dass er
jetzt in wenigen Tagen sein Restaurant
Karl Lauterbach übergeben wird soweit
ich gehört habe hat man nicht damit
gerechnet das liegt aber auch an den
unterschiedlichen politischen Kulturen
Angela Merkel hat das ganze Gegenteil
sie hat er die geschlossene Auster
präferiert als den offensiven
Kommunikator den Lauterbacher darstellt
und insofern ist das schon auch ein
Experiment Angela Merkel wollte gerade
nicht diese Leute die sich in die
Öffentlichkeit dringen die immer da sind
Rossbach hat nie ein Fuß auf die Erde
gekriegt insofern ist Olaf Scholz mutig
und wir werden sehen ob das
gesundheitspolitische der ganzen
Pandemie Bewältigung zuträglich ist
lederschlips noch Flieger Anstieges ja
schon länger ob du lieber sein was eine
Tochter fand das müssen also ein
bisschen altmodischen fand das als dass
ein Paket ein bisschen aussieht wie
zerstreuter Professor wie kommt sie da
wie kommst du darauf
behindert und jetzt holt Olaf Scholz ihn
ins Kabinett warum hat er sich dazu
durchgerungen und wie ist diese
Entscheidung getroffen oder Scholz hat
es gerade nur so bissl angedeutet
ja die beiden waren mal erbitterte
Konkurrenten um den Parteivorsitz aber
das hat die SPD ganz gut hingekriegt
dass alle die damals diese Roadshow
gemacht haben da sind ja ganz viele
Pärchen gegeneinander angetreten sich
danach dann doch zusammengerauft haben
immerhin ist Olaf Scholz dann ja auch
unter den anderen Sieger nämlich unter
Saskia esken und Norbert Walter-Borjans
zum Kanzlerkandidaten ausgerufen worden
das ist fast so als ob das ein bisschen
sogar eine Art Gruppentherapie war weil
die sind damals ja durch ganz
Deutschland gereist und haben halt ganz
viele Auftritte gemacht und vielleicht
haben sie sich da doch ein bisschen
persönlich besser kennengelernt vom Typ
her sind die sehr unterschiedlich ja das
stimmt aber Olaf Scholz kann auch mit na
ja sage ich mal exzentrischen
Persönlichkeiten gut umgehen und das
kann dann sogar harmonieren
hat so in den letzten Tagen gemerkt dass
natürlich auch der Druck und der Wunsch
aus der Bevölkerung nach Karl Lauterbach
seine Spuren hinterlassen hat und wohl
auch noch mal einen nachdenken auch bei
Olaf Scholz in Gang gesetzt hat zumal er
weiß das Coronavirus so große
Bewährungsprobe wird also er wird jetzt
vereidigt und dann könnte die Situation
in den ersten Tagen seiner Kanzlerschaft
auf dem Intensivstation noch mal
schlimmer werden das heißt wenn Corona
nicht in den Griff zu kriegen ist dann
ist auch gleich schon seine
Kanzlerschaft sehr beschädigt und
insofern ist es da vielleicht dann gar
nicht schlecht auf einen Experten zu
setzen Angelika im Hintergrund sieht man
so ein bisschen da versammelt sich
drängelt sich jetzt noch so ein
Grüppchen was ist denn da hinten los ist
jetzt kein Lauterbach der einzige der
steht ja ganz vor der Kamera noch da ein
paar Interviews gibt oder wer stellt
sich den Fragen der Journalist nein nein
nein die die Minister sind ich habe
sofort den Abgang gemacht die sind
gleich mit Olaf Scholz durch die Tür und
dann hoch in die Räume die dann halt den
Partei geranten vorbehalten sind ab
gezwitschert hinter uns steht noch Lars
Klingbeil das ist der designierte neue
Parteichef und macht ein gibt ein paar
Hintergrundinformationen
vielen Dank Angelika Hellemann und zur
Scholz Reporterin dort aus dem
Willy-Brandt-Haus der SPD Parteizentrale
kurz nach dem Urlaub stolz bekannt
gegeben hat wen er höchstpersönlich auf
die Minister und Ministerinnen Liste
geschrieben hat und die Liste GEMA noch
mal ganz kurz durch Peter und Reife und
zum Studio Peter Thiede Ralf Schuler
unsere beiden Politik Chefreporter hier
aus dem politischen Berlin was ist noch
überraschend vielleicht erstmal
insgesamt die Besetzung es gibt 17
Pfosten 9 x man 8 mal Frau ist es jetzt
halbe-halbe oder ist es das nicht also
sagen wir so um 11 Uhr Olaf Scholz dir
so betont dass es paritätisch Bild
besetzt muss ich aber anschreiben lassen
dass unter ihm paritätisch will das ist
alles unter indem man herrscht Parität
mit ihm herrscht sie nicht ja sorry wenn
man rechnen können ist halt ganz klar
ist dann halt nicht halbe halbe da
braucht man nicht drumrum zu reden
den nsu-untersuchungsausschuss sie hat
wirklich in diesem Bereich Qualitäten
sie ist die Wahl in Politikerin dort in
Hessen Überraschung die hochholen bei
wirklich viel haben damit gerechnet dass
sie die nächste die Spitzenkandidaten
für den hessischen Landtagswahlkampf
Landwirt und dann für mich eine große
Überraschung ist Christine lambrecht als
Untertaunus Ministerin und desto länger
ich darüber nachdenke desto besser ist
die Entscheidung und der so wirklich
auch positiv überrascht wenn ich von dir
Bescheid von der Entscheidung weil es
gibt in der S-Line ganz große
pazifistische Strömung Rolf Mützenich
SPD Fraktionschef z.b. steht explizit
dafür nehmen dass 2% Ziel er für eine
Abrüstung wir haben aber nur Schrott an
mir Olaf Scholz Muster also jemand
hinsetzen der auf Format hat ja auch
starkes und Christine lambrecht hat es
in der Diskussion um die Strafrechts
Verschärfung bei Kinderpornografie und
bei ähnlichem gezeigt da hat sie ihre
eigene Position verändert und hat dann
so hart dazu gestanden dass die Parteien
mit dir mitgegangen sind dass sie
wunderbar durchgeboxt und so jemanden
zum ständiger sind die lässt sich auch
nicht 645 gerade machen oder irgendwas
die ist wirklich gut die hat die hat
auch parteiintern gutes denn in die
kriegt man da auch nicht weg so jemand
hinzustellen ging den dann auch die
Pazifisten und und andere angiften
müssen das ist für die SPD und vor allem
für für Olaf Scholz wirklich gut der hat
sich da schlau abgesichert
bunt ist dafür ein ich nicht zuständig
man kann das Fördern man kann es an
Reizen der bricht es aber der also da da
wollen wir garnicht zuständigkeitsstreit
gehen weil wenn der Bus nicht muss der
Bund der Bund verspricht das und 100000
davon sollen auch noch sozial finanziert
sein da darf man gespannt sein in Berlin
z.b. wo ja die SPD regiert funktioniert
das seit Jahren nicht da dürfte es
interessante Dialoge gehen bei
lauterbach ist mir noch eingefallen dass
es ja eigentlich auch deshalb ein ganz
kluger Schachzug ist weil er ja einer
natürlich gewachsener
Gesundheitsminister ist wenn du jetzt
einen anderen dahin setzt und du hast
dein Leben immer noch ein Leben
Kommunikationstalent Gesundheitsminister
hättest du nur unterschiedliche
Machtzentrum also so gesehen auch ganz
gut und Entwicklung kann man große
Akzente setzen das wird immer
unterschätzt es ist eigentlich der neben
Außenminister der da unterwegs ist beim
Entwicklungs Ressort da sind Milliarden
die strategisch investiert werden in
Entwicklungsländer und da wird sehen
wird man sehen auf vorschulze neben
Umwelt was ich bisher gemacht hat da zum
Zuge kommen